夫和小姨子之间相互看不顺眼或者说排斥，
那是最好的关系了，
就是姐夫和小姨夫的关系，
如果说看顺眼了，
那麻烦大了一手，
你要想一下我该怎么处理我跟姐夫他们之间的关系，
我姐姐是对我很好很好的，
今年刚过年的时候，
我出来工作嘛，
我妈妈是不放心我一个人走夜路，
然后就说跟我姐姐一下，
说可不可以让你妹妹先去你们家借住一下，
然后也就是有个一个月，
等一个月以后，
就那个天黑了就晚了吧，
然后就让她回来就可以了，
然后当时他们是答应了，
然后等我搬进去的时候是第几，
我忘了是第几天了，
我都听到我姐姐和姐夫他们在吵架，
就是我姐夫的意思是你让他走吧，
我受不了他在聊，
所以我觉得我们一家三口，
然后多了一个人，
我很不好，
就那种浑身不舒服的那种，
然后那个时候就我我姐姐就说我就这么一个妹妹啊，
你不能这样，
就总之就是吵了很久嘛，
他们后来吵到就是要我姐姐说那不行，
我们离婚吧，
我觉得我不能因为我我妈妈有时候不能因为我去伤害了他们的感情，
就说那先这样吧，
等试用期过了以后，
工作稳定了就自己出来搬出来住嘛，
晚上就大不了我去接你一下，
本来事情就应该结束了，
我后来找到房子还没有搬。
出去之前有一个大娘给我介绍了一个相亲对象，
当时那天我回家，
然后我姐夫突然说请你们去吃个饭，
我当时觉得我跟他只见了一面，
还没有确定关系，
也没有怎么样，
就有点那个很突然，
当时我姐姐说她想请就请吧，
就那样去就去，
去了以后她在那个饭局里面，
然后她突然说了一句，
说让我去我那个相亲对象家里面去住，
我当时就很生气，
然后就说那你们就先吃，
我就先走，
然后我就问那个下期对象，
我有点不舒服，
你送我回家吧，
是这样，
然后我们就走了，
他事后怪我跟他甩了脸色，
然后我现在是搬出来了，
搬出来了自己也独立了嘛，
跟他们没有关系，
但是一到过年啊什么的还是会在一起，
后面还会有很多的事情会在一起，
我不知道是不是自己有点小心眼，
然后就觉得说，
所以这件事情太斤斤计较，
但是我就是不知道该怎么样去用一个很好的心态去平衡跟他们之间的关系，
我没有哭过，
是有点紧张，
然后这两天感冒，
有点鼻音，
但这事儿啊，
从源头上来讲，
这事儿本就是你和你的妈妈考虑不周全，
这事儿本就不该干，
本就不该住到姐姐姐夫家里面去，
对，
真的哦，
从你和你妈妈这个角度来说，
那是我亲姐姐，
那是我亲姐夫呀，
我这个工作有难处了，
我过渡一下怎么了呢？
就不该就不该住进去，
就本来姐夫。
和小姨子之间的关系，
当你这种情况已经算是很好的了，
姐夫和小姨子之间相互看不顺眼或者说排斥，
那是最好的关系了，
就是姐夫和小姨子的关系，
如果说看顺眼了，
那麻烦更大。
你理解龙慧姐想表达这意思吗？
跟你姐夫之间这个关系其实已经是很好的状态了，
那你姐夫看你不顺眼哈，
你看你姐夫也不顺眼，
挺好的，
本来你和你姐夫就该有这种距离感，
就该有这个分寸感，
正好你俩看不顺眼，
以后的话，
逢年过节你就想，
我和我姐有这样的缘分，
我们是世界上最亲的人，
但我和我姐夫没有这样的缘分，
我不能把他当哥哥，
不能把他当亲人，
我也不能把他当呃，
依靠就这那的，
所以我俩只要别打架就可以了，
也不要让我姐为难，
也不要在我姐面前去哭诉，
说姐夫为什么看我不顺眼，
姐夫如果爱你的话，
他应该对我好，
他应该包容我，
不要去为难你姐，
如果你姐和你姐夫他俩关情关来的过日子，
能把日子过好就很不容易了，
嗯，
其些我知道，
然后我也能理解这些东西，
就是觉得他是我不理他，
就有的时候我就跟他，
就只他保持距离嘛，
有后面有见过几次，
就只他持一个距离，
他就觉得我给他甩脸是吧，
怎么怎么样，
他他有的时候他又想就是来是好呀，
就是。
我们一起去玩一下怎么样，
但是我又觉得你以前这么对我，
然后现在我搬走了，
然后跟你没有关系，
我不知道他是讨厌我这个人，
还是说讨厌我住在他家里这事儿啊，
怎么说呢，
就心里面承认，
我和我姐夫之间呢，
我们可能哎，
没有这样的缘分，
没有这样说他把我当妹妹，
我把他当哥哥，
当亲人，
这样的缘分对我们就是客客气气的，
客客气气的是什么意思呢？
我不要刻意的甩脸色给他看，
就是大家一起吃饭的话，
该一起吃饭，
咱们就一起吃个团圆饭是吧，
他要说一起出去玩的话，
就说哎呀，
我身体不太舒服，
姐夫我就不去了，
少接触，
尽量不接触可以吗？
没要在他们家住很久，
我是住了，
有她是那天下雪，
下完雪之后是10天，
只有10天，
因为他们生气我就走了嘛，
我知道，
就是我不想因为我去在我们家，
我姐姐他们之间的感情，
还是我妈妈是说她那个工作的试用期是一个月，
对，
确实是过渡，
这点是当时做的不太好嘛，
那个只是希说过渡一下，
如果这份工作能够安定下来，
我就搬出去，
去自己租房子，
如果说那个工作他过不了那个试用期，
就是找房子也是需要时间的嘛，
就是比较那什么，
我是觉得是我提前跟你沟通过，
然后呢，
你们当时是答应了的，
进去以后你你不满意，
你可以直接说我不喜欢让他来，
然后我也不会去。
姑娘，
这事儿不赖你啊，
这事儿源头上就是你妈妈这个人没有什么智慧，
你妈妈这个人危机感不好，
就不该，
从源头上你妈妈就不该安排这事儿，
就不该安排你住到你姐姐姐夫家里面去，
明白吗？
你也不用去探讨说我姐夫到底是不喜欢我这个人呢，
还是不希望我住到他家里去呢？
这件事情没有意义，
没有意义就是你和你姐夫没有这个缘分，
那我们没有这个缘分，
我们只要不让我姐为难就可以了，
我的姐夫他也是别让我姐为难，
我也是别让我姐为难，
只要我跟我姐夫不打架，
别甩脸色，
对吧？
坐在一个桌子上相互阴阳怪气的去怼对方就可以了，
是不是你就过自己的日子？
既然跟姐夫没有这样的缘分，
也不用听姐夫的建议，
也不用听姐夫的安排，
对吧？
姐夫那件事情也做的非常的不对，
他不应该把你和你相亲的那个对象请过来吃饭，
让你搬到你相亲对象那儿去，
这件事情他做的非常不对，
就是因为这件事生他，
你姐夫这个人的话也不可深交，
也没有必要冰释前嫌，
也没有必要化解，
就这么啊，
哎，
客客气气的，
就这么一辈子就保持这样的关系，
对吧？
我不把你的你姐夫看，
你也别想把我当小姨子看，
你也别想来干涉我的生活就挺好啊，
就这么关系处就挺好是不是？
好少接触啊，
最好是不接触最好，
什么事儿的话别跟你姐夫单线联系了，
就跟你姐联系，
我一直是跟姐姐联系，
没有跟姐夫联系过，
对，
那就行了，
以后的话你的事儿你也不用对吧，
也不用老听你姐夫就这那的啊，
他如果想发表一点什么意见的话，
当面别怼他，
把他当个屁放了就完事儿了，
好的，
嗯，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
这事儿还好办，
姑娘啊，
就这事儿不是最坏的状态，
这事儿不是最难处的关系，
这事儿是非趁好处的关系，
就是我不处关系，
怕就怕那种姐夫跟小姨夫开顺眼了，
关系可就不好处了。
哎，
我说，
所以你刚刚上来的时候，
我心里还咯噔一下，
我说这男人不好处，
哎，
我心里还担心呢，
万一是姐夫跟小姨子他俩看对眼嘛，
你这关系怎么处呢？
啊，
怎么处，
这正好他俩看不对，
看不顺眼是吧，
姐夫看不顺眼，
这关系可好处了，
就是不处的，
解题思路一下子就出来了啊，
你们有没有觉得现在啊，
就是人和人的关系，
就像做那个应用题，
像小时候做那个数学应用题一样，
一旦这个解题思路一出来了之后，
就抽丝剥茧就可好了，
一下子就理顺了啊，
就那感觉，
你看刚才这个姐妹，
她这个关系就是解题思路就是别处哎，
不处我。
你不要听，
不需要听你的话，
也不要对你有所期待，
也不要对你有所任何的约束，
就是咱俩不处关系，
哎，
就挺好，
那有的朋友说姐姐最尴尬，
那人家姐姐已经有孩子了呀，
是吧？
人家他们两口子在关起门来的时候，
没有其他这些事儿的时候，
人家两口子关起门来能把日子过好呀，
所以就是大家都是善良的人，
都不要让姐姐为难就可以了。